à l'université de bourgogne la mission
handicap existe depuis une quinzaine
d'années une chargée d'accueil un chargé
de mission est en service civique
rémy malvoyants reconnues travailleurs
handicapés
son poste est aménagé un clavier à
grosses touches et sur une clé usb un
logiciel de grossissement grâce auquel
il peut lire son écran avant d'arriver
ici des rémy titulaire d'une licence de
journalisme a vu partout les portes se
fermer devant lui à cause de son
handicap ou pour journalistes moscou où
le plus posé problème c'est à l'absence
de permis de conduire ce que j'ai avec
ma vision je ne peux pas conduire
j'ai cherché un bon travail sédentaire
ou on pourrait pas objecté le fait que
j'ai pas le permis pour pas me prendre
en fait j'ai refait un bts en assurance
et j'ai travaillé un an sur une
plateforme téléphonique mais l'appareil
en fait au niveau des handicaps le poids
ce n'était pas totalement adapté parce
que j'avais pas les bonnes personnes
ressources pour me dire ce qu'il nous
fallait
chargé d'organiser des événements de
sensibilisation ou handicap
rémy a aussi la gestion au sein de la
bibliothèque universitaire d'un local
spécialement aménagé pour les étudiants
handicapés table à hauteur modulable
dalle interactive logiciel
d'accessibilité visuel mais comment la
société peut-elle garantir une vraie
place aux personnes handicapées cécile
valence ya la mère de rémy a des idées
sur la question
elle lui a répondu sur mech point org
lors d'une consultation citoyenne des
propositions concrètes c'est de ce
serait de coupler un emploi de personnes
handicapées avec un emploi de personnes
seniors volontaires en fin de carrière
qui permettrait à ce senior de former le
jeune handicapé des propositions qui ont
été retenues et qu'elle présentera à
paris le 11 février lors de la
conférence nationale sur le handicap